can you get a pair of scissors please oh
thanks - brilliant for sponsoring a
section of this video so just over a
week ago I started displaying symptoms
of the corona virus I think I picked it
up about two weeks ago
and since then I have been in
self-isolation hence V what the admins
have started calling the kuroh t turns
out still can't grow a beard this isn't
Shane this is Richie just how it grows
but I thought I should do a little vlog
about the experiences at the past week
or so but also document what's going to
happen over the next couple of days
because we're about to enter a very
unusual period in the house first though
I've let me just okay I'm currently
recording this on day 11 after I started
displaying symptoms of corona virus and
at the time of recording I feel about
90% of the way recovered what's been
interesting with this virus is that
different people seem to get very
different symptoms there are certain
symptoms which are much more common than
others but some people will report fever
other people seem to report chills or
joint pain or nausea or a rash I seem to
have got a selection a pick-and-mix of
the symptoms first of all it manifested
as a really quite profound fatigue but
then it manifested as a dry persistent
cough which kind of set alarm bells
ringing but I just thought that was a
cover I thought this was my brain you
know telling me that something was down
it wasn't just because you know corona
virus is out there in the world you're
imagining this thing but then
unfortunately I also developed really
kind of difficulty breathing I was
getting out of breath just sitting up in
bed I was getting out of breath trying
to watch youtube videos and everything
together made me yeah not great would
not recommend the experience now you may
well say okay Simon but how do you know
that you actually had the virus did you
get yourself tested the answer to that
is yes I did get myself tested because
pixel girl my partner is an essential
worker so she was able to get tested and
I was able to go with her but
interestingly my tests came back
negative the test that we did was a
self-administered one so you drove up to
a testing station you opened the window
a crack and they popped a sachet with
instructions and a kit through the
window and then he went and parked up
and it was a deep
unpleasant experience I called up a
friend of mine I went to uni with who's
now practicing medical doctor and in a
very breathy conversation we learned
that basically the self-administered
Tessa knee okay have a surprisingly high
false negative rate twenty maybe thirty
percent so despite that negative result
on the test
my friend was pretty convinced that I
actually had the virus because the
severity of the symptoms I was
displaying and he was actually quite
concerned he said if things got much
worse especially regards to the
breathing I really should be going into
a store to get an oxygen support
fortunately I didn't get any worse and
so could stay at home but this posed a
problem my partner pixel girl was an
essential worker and also a somatic so
an at-risk group of coronavirus and
while she likely already had the virus
at this point at the recommendation of
my doctor friend we decided to try and
minimize her viral load by self
isolating within the house she was to
live entirely downstairs while I lived
entirely upstairs that meant that we had
minimal contact and only shared the
bathroom which it was my responsibility
to keep spotless be clean
she on the other hand because the
kitchen was downstairs had to do all the
cooking and washing up for both of us
the only time we could spend together
was socially distant meals either on the
stairs well she could leave food for me
on a tray or out the window and
previously we've been in a long-distance
relationship from the UK to Spain
whereas now we were in a short distance
relationship from upstairs to downstairs
this was tough because she was so close
and yet so far
but ultimately worth it to try and
minimize her risk this short distance
relationship has to last from when we
started it which was a couple of days
after I start displaying major symptoms
until a week after I stopped displaying
those symptoms so it's about two weeks
and that's a really long time to be so
close to your partner to your
significant other but not be allowed to
actually spend time with them to not
actually be able to live your life
normally so close but so far kind of
thing
I miss you can I get a few comments
about what it's like to be I want to
interview you but I can't get close
enough
such distraction I don't know what you
mean what's it been like being in a
short distance with me what's the last
week been like it's been great I haven't
had to see you at all but you had to
cook for me and do all my washing and
all the washing up and everything yeah
it's been less good do you think our
relationships stronger for this yes
question mark well if I swing this in
your face probably not thank you for
this exclusivity obviously when I was
really sick I was just laying in bed I
wasn't doing very much because I wasn't
capable of doing very much I literally
got tired out listening to a podcast but
as the symptoms abated
and I found myself getting better I was
able to start doing more each day I was
able to start replying to messages get
out of bed that played the piano a
little bit and so it's only really been
in the last couple of days where I
really felt like I've been missing out
by being an isolation up here because
there's only really been in the last
couple of days I've been able to do
stuff unfortunately I haven't needed to
do very much up here apart from the
incident so I thought the most
interesting things that happened to me
this week would be getting better from
coronavirus but no let me just go into
the bedroom a second and go up Erica
does have an eye that's do you want
[Music]
don't make me cough on you because I
will do it I'm gonna have to ask you to
leave that way you birdbrain
[Music]
you know having no to leave the house
for two weeks and I hadn't left the
house before them for any reason for
about a week before then because I was
kind of feeling a little bit ill but not
really ill so I haven't been out there
for the best part of a month and much as
there is a whole world of possibilities
out there there's literally everything
in human existence apart from the
contents of this house I think I'm
really looking forward to when we're
allowed to in the self isolation it's
just me able to spend time with pics
with Kel who's literally downstairs rest
of the world take it or leave it just
give me some time on the sofa watching
Netflix with my partner I think in any
situation you have to look for the
positives at the recommendation of
seemingly everyone I try to get back to
normal as I recovered by having a
regular schedule every day as soon as I
was able I would get up take medication
do some piano practice and learn a
little chemistry this is one of those
things I've been meaning to do for years
but I've never found the time a global
pandemic isn't necessarily the best time
to push yourself but every day I found a
few minutes to improve myself and feel a
small sense of achievement I think I
learned it's important to set these
small achievable goals before moving on
to the big stuff if nothing else just to
give you a sense of momentum but I think
the isolation led to positives beyond
just that perhaps it's just a case of
absence makes the heart grow fonder but
I felt our relationship had definitely
improved I thought we got much better at
communicating because we couldn't just
hug stuff out we had to talk through our
problems by putting a small separation
between us I think we both gained
perspective and gained appreciation and
Trust for what the other does for us
[Music]
thanks tonight is the final night I'll
be in soft isolation to the final night
I'm here alone in bed so tomorrow I get
to actually spend some time with I'll
get to leave the house and get her she
gets to come up here and sleep in her
own bed again so it's great the occasion
I thought I just did a little something
stupid but hopefully fun
can you get a pair of scissors please
because I would like to welcome you to
the grunge if you don't come up welcome
to the grand reopening
[Laughter]
so defense spending new two weeks apart
short distance relationship has changed
the relationship yeah it has changed and
it's got its approved I mean it was
great before was improved now so because
I didn't see it for two weeks and when
you don't see someone you miss them like
annoying trades downstairs for two weeks
so I kind of put them to the back of my
mind forgot about them so when I saw you
again I was like wow so you're saying
that it's improved the relationship
because you forgot the bad bits about me
I guess so I was gonna come in here and
say that it's made a more trusting I'm
more patient I think we've got better at
communicating yes but also you forgot my
bad bits yeah also the thing is that I
feel so loved certainly with the past
day or two and we've actually been have
spent time together we've felt more
mature in our relationship just having
that little separation I don't know to
me at least it makes it feel like we've
got better at being us
that's great as I mentioned earlier I
made a small part of my daily routine in
the isolation learning chemistry which I
hadn't studied for some 13 years since
my GCSE and have always wanted to get
back - you may have noticed that I was
using brilliance to do this which was a
great experience all about learning
through solving problems and I'm gonna
get something wrong learning about why
you did so brilliant were actually kind
enough to sponsor this video and after
spending a week learning from one of
their courses I cannot recommend them
highly enough if you're interested in
developing a scientific or mathematical
skill then I genuinely believe that
their method of learning by doing is the
best way to learn I did chemistry but
you can take courses in other areas of
science computer science and mathematics
and they all have great illustrations
interactive problems and a well-written
course structure so if you'd like to
make learning a small part of your daily
routine like I did then head to
brilliant org slash the Simon Clarke
link below and the first 200 people to
do so will get 20% off their annual
subscription thanks to brilliant for
agreeing to sponsor this quite unusual
video thank you for watching the video
and if you're a regular viewer for being
patient with me to make it well I
recovered this experience was not great
and I wouldn't wish it on anyone but I
hoped I was able to show that some
positives came out of it and that maybe
this video was one of them if you
enjoyed it please do give it a like give
it a share if you fancy subscribe to the
channel if you're not already and thank
you again for watching I'll see you the
next one